are you ready vanessa
sorry i can't
okay is it can you hear me are we
starting yes
okay there's a lot of noise in the
background sorry
okay i think we can start
okay
okay great so i'd like to talk about
corset estimates and interventions which
is partly a reflection on
what we can learn from randomized trials
when we do observational data analysis
and the other way around what the
observational data analysis might learn
from randomized trials
and but als okay so this is this is the
overview and as i said observational
data analysis emulate randomized trials
clinical trials on the other hand start
looking
for help from causal inference
but really what i also want to talk
about is a new notion of s demand which
is
known as now as separable effects and
this is relevant to randomized trials
with intercurrent events
and when
things happen after randomization but
before you measure the outcome people
often turn to causal mediation analysis
and this is
where there might be an alternative in
the separable effects
and
in particular i find the the separable
effects useful in a survival setting and
especially in competing with settings so
this is um what in the end of the talk i
want to focus on
okay but let's first um
i have to do something first because
there's a i can't see the chat and i
don't want to see the chat there you go
okay
um so
uh in epidemiology mostly this is where
from where i come from mostly we have
observational data
and in order to focus the analysis
better and to avoid lots of problems it
has become a good idea to
use the target trial emulation approach
to analyze observational data so even if
observational data is not from a
randomized trial it's good to think
about what would be the ideal trial
and it also focuses on what is the
decision problem that we want to address
by analyzing these observational data
it makes the
intervention explicit because we have to
formulate a trial
where we would carry out this
intervention so even though it's
observational data we have to be very
clear about what the intervention is
and this
has the advantages that we formulate a
clear s demand so what is it that we
want to estimate becomes very clear by
taking this approach
and it also avoids the avoidable biases
like immortal time bias or
prevalent user biases etc that are
common especially when we analyze
electronic health records
on the other hand clinical trials
we have we typically have randomization
so what else do we want we can randomize
we can just look at the outcome in the
two groups treatment and control group
everything's fine no problem wonderful
but no things happen after randomization
and this these have become known
as by the summary term of intercurrent
events what might happen is people
especially when you study an older
population people might die before you
can measure the outcome they might not
adhere to the treatment or they switch
treatment or they have side effects etc
all kinds of things happen
and these might either make
make it impossible
to measure the outcome like when death
occurs or they give a new meaning maybe
to treatment if people don't adhere to
the treatment that was intended for
example
so also notice that this spoils the
randomization because if you
limit your analysis then to those who
stay alive then in this group the
treatment is not randomized anymore you
have a selection effect possibly
uh so people have um started to ask well
what is our s demand then even if we
have a randomization if we have a trial
it's randomized what is our estimate
then what method should we use and they
turn to causal inference and there's a
guideline of an international
medicine agency um that gives some
guidance as to what to what to do or
that people when they design randomized
trials they should explicitly
address how they want to deal with
inter-current events and this is what's
become known as the ich9 addendum so in
this context i want to
basically contrast these approaches a
little bit
so when we have
observational data and we
formulate a target trial what we mean is
that we think about what is the ideal
intervention that reflects our research
question
what do we allow in our target trial
because we can actually disregard
certain practical ethical financial
constraints that is in a way what we
really want because
within those constraints we can conduct
a randomized trial
but it's because we are interested in
subpopulations that are maybe more frail
pregnant women also that are more
difficult to study in an actual clinical
trial but we want to look at
observational data in order to inform
decisions also for these subpopulations
but we can
do other things in our
ideal trial in our target trial we can
imagine we eliminate censoring we
enforce follow-up for everyone
and we might even enforce adherence uh
to the treatment for everyone er to some
extent
but what is not allowed in our target
trial um
because we wanted to be realistic we
wanted to you know to reflect a possible
hypothetically possible trial
we don't want to violate the laws of
physics we don't want to turn back time
so things like individual causal effects
are not really something that can be
formulated in a target trial
nor won't we want to look into the
future or even multiple parallel futures
which is something like
what you would need to do to formulate a
principal stratum effect we might also
want to stick to some ethical
constraints in that we don't compare
treatments that we know or maybe the
absence of treatment that we know would
kill patients so they have no relevance
in real life because it's not something
that doctors would ever do
and we might also not want to force pace
patients to stay alive because that is
not possible if we are studying an
elderly population some people are going
to die but some s demands are actually
as if we are forcing patients to stay
alive i think someone called this the um
zombie apocalypse scenario that's
forcing patients to stay alive
on the other hand randomized trials
where
we have the randomization but we might
have intercurrent events
intercurrent events where the outcome is
still defined when people don't adhere
to treatment or they switch treatment
etc
then we still have the intention to
treat analysis it's still very defined
and identified just by based on the
randomization
but what is the problem transferability
might be hampered because it's of course
valid for this type of population with
this adherence um
[Music]
behavior
and um it's still a different
interpretation than what we maybe
originally wanted so we're still
thinking about what might be the s
demand instead
um if the outcome is not defined so
if death occurs or if there are other
requirements like people you're studying
people on dialysis but then they get a
transplant
and they don't belong to the group that
you want to study anymore
in this context people have
followed more the principal stratum type
of approaches of for example looking at
the always survivors and as i would
argue this doesn't fit with the target
trial approach so remember we have a
trial but there are inter-current events
we switch to something we know from
called inference which is principal
stratum but that then again doesn't
satisfy really the target trial
demands
should we use direct effect controlling
for the mediator again this would give
us the
zombie apocalypse or um do we formulate
things via stochastic interventions
which might be another idea
so
what i want to talk about as an
alternative are separable effects
they formulate a different type of s
demand which in the context of competing
events really leads to a completely new
s demand
um
they are useful in some situations for
randomized controlled trials and they
are also an alternative to causal
mediation as demands in many other
situations i don't i don't want to say
that they are always
the solution to everything but in some
situations uh they might be an
interesting alternative
so let's have a look at the very basic
example again to start with we have a
treatment the treatment is randomized so
there's no confounding between treatment
and whatever happens afterwards
but there's only partial compliance
perhaps but due to a side effect so
people loosely say the overall effect is
reduced due to due to the partial
compliance because
uh people are supposed to get the full
dose of treatment don't get the photos
of treatment so maybe they don't get the
full effect but it's not quite clear
reduced to what
what are we comparing with
i'm
just for the sake of exposition i'm
looking at a very simple case where also
for the moment there is no confounding
between
adherence
and the outcome here
so what are possible as demands
as i mentioned one might be the
controlled direct effect
the question is is this a sensible
target trial
type quantity
are there situations where we might be
interested in enforcing adherence which
is maybe sometimes possible sometimes
feasible or at least thinkable
people can decide to definitely adhere
to the treatment but remember we don't
want to kill people if somehow adherence
is not
uh sensible because it's it
the the patient would otherwise die then
it's not something that we want to
adhere
we could modify this there are other
versions of this where it's not fully
controlled in the sense of
fixing the value so enforcing adherence
but we have a
stochastic intervention that still
separates
adherence from the treatment
that is another version of this s-demand
the alternative that i want to talk
about is
let's think about
an additional modification of treatment
so not only is treatment randomized but
we might be able to somehow
modify to some other intervention and
treatment that specifically targets the
undesirable pathway
and as an example that this isn't just a
theory or you know just just something
where we can do in our imagination
let's look at some
medical examples
and i rely on the
information from my medical
collaborators here i'm not i don't have
the medical background here but for
example statins
are supposed to the the intended effect
is to lower the ldl cholesterol
but they somehow adversely affect the
muscles and that leads to bad adherence
people don't like this
but there's another type of drug
um pcsk9 uh k9 inhibitors that also
lower ldi cholesterol but do not have
these um adverse effects on
giving you some muscle pain
so that they have the same intended
effect but they get rid of the
unintended effect and this is uh the
idea that leads to separable direct or
indirect effects
so let's look at this formally
formally we have uh for the simplest
case binary treatment uh binary mediator
let's call it a mediator this
intercurrent event good or bad adherence
and
for simplicity a binary outcome doesn't
matter
what we assume with separable effects is
that the treatment has
separate components that can
hypothetically
be
manipulated separately
so
think of
a different ingredient for example the
active ingredient
is
responsible for the intended effect and
maybe another ingredient that's
responsible for the side effect
so we would formulate our outcome the
potential outcome as a
potential outcome under two settings now
where we
set the
treatment component responsible for the
desired outcome and the mediator
component to possibly different things
and this might be a hypothetical new
drug where we have changed the chemical
composition of this new drug
so in this case the separable direct
effect would look like this we modif we
manipulate the first component that's
the desired drug effect
while we keep the second component at
the level that avoids the side effect
and therefore the bad adherence
oops
let me go back
so this would be the separable direct
effect and
it leads to if we can think about things
like this it leads maybe to new drug
developments
so actual
future
hypothesis that can be tested in future
trials where we can
investigate these sort of new drug
effects here
it's helpful to look at this with an
extended graph to represent also later
the assumptions when i come to the
assumptions so in this extended graph we
have the original treatment and then we
have the two treatment components
observationally
with the situation as it is now not a
hypothetical future new drug but now
these are just identical but our s
demand would be formulated in terms of
interventions on these two a the am and
the a y so here am activates the
mediating pathway a y activates the
pathway that avoids the
mediator the inter-current event and the
hypothetical intervention is that we can
set these to different values
even though for the moment maybe with a
drug as it is we can't do that yet
the target of inference as before might
be for example the expected
value of y of the potential outcome y on
the settings of a y and am if we
manipulate this here it's a direct
effect if we manipulate
am it's an indirect effect
and oops let me go back again so the
original idea was uh due to thomas and
jamie uh on this and there's also more
recent work where this is nicely
described as what we want so our target
trial here would be a forearm trial
where we set this to the value zero and
one and this to the value and one so we
have four arms
but the data that we have is this it's a
two arm trial where we have only
randomized the original version of a
so what about identification
first of all we need to believe that
what we do in our two arm trial this y
potential outcome y a is the same as
what we would do in a forearm trial
where both have the same value
so it's a certain sort of consistency
assumption
and then we need the separability
assumptions where
we need to make sure that the components
are not informative respectively for the
other quantities so a y is not
informative for the immediate or the
inter current event given relevant
information on the path and the other
way around am is not informative for y
and this has to hold in the forearm
trial
so this is not something that holds
observationally because observationally
we do not have a y and am
it has to hold in the forearm
hypothetical forearm trial
and then under these assumptions and
some of the standard assumptions of
causal inference i'm not even talking
much about confounding here let's just
assume a was randomized we obtain the
identifying function
the known well-known mediational g
formula
and
once we are back to this formula we have
many approaches available in the
literature to estimate this so it's um
basically we're telling a different
story for
something that we already know but the
difference is to make us think about uh
the treatment um and the actual
interventions in our hypothetical trial
in a different way
um now
to talk a bit more about the assumptions
i have so far assume no confounding
between mediator and
why or between the intercurrent event
that's not realistic a is what we can
randomize so this
is okay but everything else might be
confounded
in this case the assumptions say that
we
we need we can the separable effects are
identified if we have data on c
but it would not be identified if we
don't have data on c so one of the
assumptions would be violated so the
assumptions i didn't say that the
assumptions are basically absence of
these separations between a m and y and
d separation between a y and m given
suitable information
now you may have noticed that i told you
a story about a side effect but i
haven't put the side effect in the graph
so
really a good practice is to put
your whole story into the graph so
the story might be like this um with our
separate treatment components then
there's a side effect then there's the
adherence and then there's the outcome
that we can measure
this is very restrictive because there
are lots of edges missing here in
reality it might be that the side effect
itself directly affects the outcome
in this case again we have
a lack of identification unless we also
have data on the side effects
or it might also be that the side effect
is actually um
due to the active ingredient that also
does the intended
effect and then
we also have a lack of identifiability
so it's
it's always good practice to put the
whole story in the graph
now the problem really if you think
about it occurs because these are things
that happen over time
so there's randomization when things
happen people decide have developed side
effects develop
whatever switch the treatment etc and
then at some later point in time we
measure the outcome
so really we should maybe look at things
via processes uh stochastic processes in
a time dependent way also in many cases
survival or time to event
outcomes are
what we look at in randomized trials
um so it turns out that many the typical
notions of direct and indirect effects
become problematic in survival settings
but i'm not going to go into detail
because i'm already running out of time
a little bit
uh instead we can take the separable
effects approach
and um i will here focus on computing
event settings because here it really
leads to the new as demand
so in competing events
we have
we might for example want to study the
time
uh uh
so treatment for for cancer and we are
measuring the death from that particular
type of
cancer the duration and that's due to
other causes is then a computing event
so we're measuring the time to the first
of two events and we make a note which
one happens is a death from cancer or
death due to other causes
this can be represented more formally by
accounting processes um we don't need
much formalism here um
if we have a randomized treatment
randomization of a
then we can describe the total effects
are in fact two effects one for each
event the total effects are
for example in terms of the cumulative
instance curves uh the probability that
the um
that the the
one event occurs and that this event is
uh of type k that would be this um
event specific cumulative incidence
under treatment a or a star that's that
would be a contrast of these two curves
would be a total effect
this is
this is identified without any further
ado we have we might have to deal with
censoring if we have and we assume
independent censoring
let's look at an example
here the
outcome of interest is death from
prostate cancer and um that from other
causes might occur
we have a treatment a new treatment
called des
and
it's a randomized trial with a placebo
group
and a treatment group and here we have
all the four curves
for the dotted ones for deaths from
other causes and the solid ones is death
from prostate cancer over time
i think these are month
the unit thing as you can see
the um
from the dotted lines the treatment
increases the incidence throughout of
death from other causes whereas from the
solid lines you can see that the
treatment decreases the incidence
from death from prostate cancer
these are total effects overall effects
now we want
people
want to describe the if on
of treatment on
death from prostate cancer alone not the
total effect because what might happen
let me go back what might uh
one interpretation here is maybe
treatment kills people from other causes
and therefore we see fewer deaths from
prostate cancer
okay so this is why people are usually
not so happy necessarily with these um
as demands here oops
so
what is common in the literature
unfortunately is to consider the
competing event as a censoring event but
what does this mean it means we are
estimating um something in a
hypothetical setting where we eliminate
the competing event which means
eliminating death due to other reasons
and that's usually not a a sensible
estimate this corresponds to the
controlled direct effect or to maybe a
halfway zombie apocalypse because
created
there is a um a
nice paper also discussing this in the
context of
dementia research
if you want to look at this so let's
look at separable effects instead
um we are going to imagine now that
treatment has two components a y and am
one that activates the pathway to the
event of interest and one that activates
the pathway through the computing event
and then we can
formulate the separable effects in terms
of the
cumulative intensity curve by saying
well the direct effect is when we
manipulate this component and the
indirect effect is when we manipulate
this component here
and this is in the context of computing
events on novel
as demand
let's return to the example to
illustrate this like this
first of all do we have separability do
we believe in this assumption as a
fundamental assumption is is treatment
even separable in principle let alone is
it then identified from the data we have
so is it is this inseparable and
one medical hypothesis could be
where this treatment it has a
testosterone suppressing function to it
and it has another function to it which
has something to do with coagulation
which might in fact increase the risk of
stroke and if these can be separated if
you can find different
ingredients uh chemical components to
retain the testosterone suppressing
without this
coagulation effect
and there is in fact a different drug
not the es but this drug that i can't
pronounce where
this might be the case so it has a
coagulating effect then
that would be a plausible hypothesis and
if we do the analysis with these data
looking at the same two events again
event of interest from prostate cancer
that from other causes is our
competing event and we now have green
curve
which is the curve where we intervene to
set a y to 1 and am to 0
this means that the
difference between the red and the green
curve is the direct effect and this is
rather large it's almost the same as the
turtle effect and the difference between
the green and the red curve is the
indirect effect which is rather small so
in this case under the assumptions that
we have made and they are strong
assumptions this would suggest that
the effect that we see is
due to the direct effect of this
testosterone suppression
the analysis was however
assuming no time
no post treatment confounding and that's
unlikely when we have processes over
time and we have generalized this
in this work here and it makes things
more complicated but it's still feasible
of course
and there are various other
generalizations also
this was basically on a discrete time
assuming discrete time models there's
nice work from
uh maths and torben on continuous time
and also on the truncation by death
problem where you then also condition on
people remaining alive which you can do
in a certain under certain assumptions
when you look at separable effects
so to come to the end of my
talk
there are many challenges in choosing
the right s demand it's helpful to look
at target trials
whether
you really only have observational data
or whether you are in a randomized trial
situation you might still want to think
about the target trial
and this has been discussed in the
clinical trials literature
and also in in guidelines here in this
addendum for example
i don't want to suggest the
one-size-fits-all solutions you always
have to think carefully about the
research crescent estimate but i think
these separable effects really offer a
new uh point of view
they prompt the elaboration of
interventions
specifically on treatment which is
something we might actually be able to
change something about in form of drag
development for example
it's compatible with the target trial
principle because it's a single word
concept and i know some of you care
about these things thank you very much
for your attention
thank you for the great talk uh we're
going to have the questions during the
panel session and i think we can go to
our second speaker
with georgia papadopoulos